welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation a
comparative approach to oncology drug
development integrating k-9 models
presented by Amy LeBlanc director
comparative oncology program Center for
cancer research National Cancer
Institute National Institutes of Health
my name is XA rocketeers and I will be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars now before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. LeBlanc I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you very much Savior and a big
thank you to the organizers of the event
and to lab roots for facilitating this
presentation I'm thrilled to have this
opportunity to share with you our work
at the National Cancer Institute and
within the Center for cancer research
which is the intramural program of the
NCI and tell you about how we integrate
dogs that naturally develop cancer into
studies of cancer biology and cancer
drug development
so the first concept that we'd like to
talk about in comparative oncology is
how similar are dogs and people to each
other and this sort of advertising slide
tells you and sort of gets across the
point of how we may look similar on the
surface but also more importantly a lot
of the diseases that affect dogs and
people are the same and more and more we
understand that appreciate differences
between adult humans and animals and the
distinguishing factors of pediatric
diseases and those that affect our
companion pets that live in our house
and our homes and so when we talk about
comparative oncology the distinction
becomes very specific to the types of
cancers that dogs and people may get and
may have in common with each other and
indeed there are remarkable similarities
and cancers that are shared between
humans and dogs for the purposes of
today's presentation will be focused per
my primarily on the companion pet dog
and in this particular publication in
2015 it really captures a lot of the
depth and breadth of types of cancers
that are shared between dogs and humans
and in that sense it becomes a really
important concept to understand these
diseases not just for the benefit of
dogs but also for the people who love
them and care for them and in doing so
we learn a lot about the types of
cancers that affect us and can leverage
this information to help those patients
so the National Cancer Institute created
the comparative oncology program to help
really dig into this question about the
value of a comparative and integrated
approach to cancer drug development and
in doing so we we strive very very much
to understand and appreciate these
naturally occurring spontaneous cancers
that develop naturally in dogs and they
really do represent a huge spread of
different types of tumors so solid
tumors both epithelial and mesenchymal
in origin but also the hematologic
cancers and these cancers develop in
dogs that are
I didn't host and in that sense there
are tumors co-evolve with the stroma
around them they are not experimentally
induced or xenografts in any way and
they also develop in dogs that
unfortunately have a fairly compressed
disease progression and a short survival
time so that really does though turn
into an advantage when studying these
diseases because you have a reasonable
amount of time to investigate things
like treatment strategies and different
diagnostic methods that really help us
understand how the natural progression
of the cancer can be appreciated in a
reasonable amount of time and then also
within the scope of veterinary medicine
over the last you know 30 years or so
veterinary oncologists have really
become quite expert in applying
chemotherapy surgery and radiotherapy
techniques both alone and in combination
with each other mirroring how physician
based medical oncology and radio
radiation therapy and and surgical
oncology are applied for human patients
and we mimic a lot of our approaches on
how things are done for human patients
and that becomes a translationally
valuable approach that then helps us
work with our physician colleagues to
understand how studies can be carried
out in dogs that mirror what happens on
the physician side and then also dogs
that develop cancer also naturally
develop therapy resistance and naturally
occurring metastases and so those types
of phenomena are not often or always
reflected in experimental mountain oral
cancer and so they become very valuable
facets of the types of diseases that we
see and it's gonna be the last point on
this slide is that there's no true
standard of care in many cases for dogs
that are presenting or for care for
their cancers you know we don't have
insurance reimbursement that's driving
the choices that people can and can't
make so ultimately the pet owner has a
lot of flexibility in determining what
is the best fit for their pet and for
their family when choosing to pursue a
treatment strategy versus just
palliative care for their pet so
this figure really helps to drive home
where all of these facets really help us
position the dog within the sort of
standard drug development paradigm where
preclinical models like mice and
laboratory beetle dogs and non-human
primates are heavily studied early on
for the purposes of safety and
tolerability of new drugs the tumor
bearing pet dog can help inform as that
path moves forward into human studies in
a variety of ways so studies that are
carried out in dogs can help answer
questions about a drugs pharmacokinetic
and pharmacodynamic o dynamic profile in
a way that may be impossible to observe
longitudinally in a mouse model we can
also investigate combination strategies
and select very specific responding
histologies and dive more deeply into
comparative studies of dose and schedule
after the recommended well after the
phase one work is conducted in people
and we're heading into a recommend phase
two dose for human studies and finally
you can think about ways that dogs can
participate in post approval setting
when we're looking at potentially
evaluating a drug and a new tumor type
or a new indication so there's value to
be had I think at many different steps
during the classic drug development path
so the idea of comparative oncology was
recently highlighted during a National
Academy of Medicine workshop and if
you're interested in more information
you can read sort of the the post
workshop impressions of the folks that
participated and responded in and gave
us feedback during this this workshop so
this paper was published shortly after
the workshop was conducted in 2016 and
really served to highlight the
opportunities in comparative oncology
moving forward maybe most importantly
this manuscript serves to offer the
challenges that we face and the
opportunities that we have to address to
really drive home that the integrated
approach does have value and can
optimize the way that we develop drugs
for human
but also helps us shed light on the
types of cancers that are affecting the
the dogs that we share our lives with
and how they can benefit from this work
as well so the comparative Oncology
Program that I direct sits within the
intramural research program of the NIH
and so this slide just sort of shows you
where we sit
organizationally within the entity of
the National Cancer Institute our parent
branch is in molecular imaging and I've
outlined the DCTV which is an extramural
division the division of cancer therapy
and diagnosis because we weren't closely
with them on a number of clinical trial
efforts and drug development programs so
that just gives you an idea to
organizationally where we sit within the
NCI
one of the most important parts of our
program that it's worth coming into some
detail about is that we have a
comparative oncology trials consortium
so this network is made up of 24 member
institutions veterinary schools within
the US and Canada that have signed a
Memorandum of Understanding and have
agreed to conduct and partner with us on
clinical trial activities that are
carried out in pet dogs with cancer and
that are designed to advance questions
on for human drug development and so
this clinical trial Network allows us to
have access to k9 patients even though
programmatically we are situated within
the NCI we don't have ready access to
veterinary patients on the NIH campus so
working with our clinical trial partners
we're able to deploy multicenter
clinical trials across a novel a whole
spectrum of novel agents so small
molecules imaging agents biologic agents
devices etc and also important to note
here that the consortium members also
work with us to provide advocacy and
access to reagents and resources that
really help enable the studies to be
carried out at dogs so when you work
with dogs there's an obvious need for
canines specifically agents and assay
expertise cell lines tumor microarrays
antibodies
cetera and so having a network of
experts within the veterinary academic
world allows us to really connect trial
sponsors with the the appropriate
pharmacodynamic assay expertise to help
interpret the data and dye more deeply
into questions of cancer biology so this
slide gives you an overview of all of
the comparative oncology trials
consortium trial that have been carried
out since the program was initiated back
in 2003 and so you can see the status of
the study whether it's gone to
publication or whether it's complete and
under analysis or whether it's an open
trial and so this just gives you an idea
again of the variety of the types of
studies that we do and how we're not you
know sort of helped held fast to any one
type of cancer we certainly have an
emphasis in osteosarcoma which I will
get to here in a little bit but we
really I think started to connect drug
trial sponsors with the appropriate
patient population and really spend a
lot of time digging into the types of
questions that the dog could within the
context of a clinical trial we can ask
and answer questions that may not be
possible or feasible to ask and other
species and that would be critical to a
drugs developer prior to or in line
parallel with human use so and then this
slide just sort of gives you the idea of
the scope of the types of biologic
samples that can be collected from dogs
with cancer so we have many many
opportunities to collect a whole
constellation really of sample types not
just tumour and maybe matched normal
adjacent tissue but also a full
complement of biologic fluids like serum
whole blood plasma urine etc that are
really helpful for post-hoc analyses and
for biomarker mining and things like
that and also remember that the the
dog's physical size and their clinical
observation within the the care of their
tumor and their enrollment on the
clinical trial allows us to see really
sample the sample serially sample these
types of tissues and fluids that really
enable some in-depth questions to be
asked during the time of drug exposure
so a really valuable opportunity there
lies within each patient that is
enrolled on these trials so next I want
to tell you a couple of stories examples
of specific trials that our program has
run and the first one is a study that we
did in naturally-occurring
canine melanoma and an interleukin 12
based immuno cytokine therapy so canine
melanoma and human melanoma have some
very interesting similarities and
differences and so visually you know
when you look at these tumors they look
fairly similar they're often pigmented
and in the case of the dog the most
common location is actually within the
oral mucosa the lips tongue the hard
palate and gums sometimes also around
the lip margin but in humans typically
melanomas a dermal disease in the skin
and and often linked to UV exposure but
there are the rare cases of human oral
mucosal melanoma depicted here it's also
interesting is that when you dive more
deeply into the biology of melanoma in
people and in dogs they have some things
that are in common that are they're
quite interesting they have a shared
pathway activation within a KT and map
kinase pathways and seem to exhibit
similar loss of p16 at p3 among other
tumor suppressor genes but they also are
similarly aggressive biologically and
they exhibit prompt recurrence after a
reception and have been complete and
have a wide propensity for metastasis
and they're also very poorly responsive
to standard small molecule cytotoxic
chemotherapy and it seems somewhat
responsive to immunotherapy so those
similarities and differences really have
led the community to believe pretty
strongly that canine melanoma is a nice
model for human melanoma and therein
lies a lot of opportunity for
immunotherapy based drug development so
to that end we conducted a trial
an interleukin 12 immuno cytokine so
aisle 12
fully human linked to a IgG based immuno
cytokine that had a homing peptide that
recognizes necrosis and this agent MHS
il-12 was evaluated in a solid tumor
study of dogs and had an expansion
cohort and in malignant melanoma and
depicted on this slide is one of the
biggest responders so this is the job
that had a really bulky maxillary
melanoma that had a complete response to
this drug visually you can see that it's
photographs and this trial was really
important because it was a fully human
construct and so you know we were not
sure necessarily how many repeated doses
of this agent could be given to dogs
given that this was not a dog specific
immuno cytokine but what I'll show you
are some of the data that really helped
move this agent forward and sort of give
you them the recent update of where this
agent stands in its human development
path and why the dog data was so
important to that progress so first of
all I just wanted to show you that
within this trial this is a example and
in this trial this is the actual study
schedule and the procedures that were
carried out during the trial and so you
get appreciation here for the clinical
management of the dogs that were
enrolled on this trial where you know we
have eligibility and and baseline
assessments baseline tumor biopsy and
draining lymph node aspiration cytology
and and flow cytometry assessment we did
clinical staging and photographs of the
target lesions we were monitoring and
then during drug exposure were able to
see really sample serum PBMCs
and then standard biochemical and
hematologic monitoring to really capture
both safety and tolerability and then
the pharmacokinetics and
pharmacodynamics ponds to the drug over
about a four-week period and the dogs
that had responsive responders to the
agent were allowed to move forward on to
additional treatment cycles
every 28 days and so what we were able
to learn from this is that dogs that
receive NHS il-12 subcutaneously achieve
memorable drug exposures and this was a
dose escalation trial so there were
multiple dosing cohorts that spanned
from 0.4 MiG per meter squared all the
way up to two point four millimeters
squared so in this slide I'm showing you
that after the time of administration of
drug we were able to capture drug levels
in serum over several hours post
administration across all the dose and
cohorts to just define the PK profile
and then similarly dogs that receive the
drug subcutaneously demonstrate the
expected pharmacodynamic or PD response
post treatment and that they have
measurable release of interferon gamma
and il-10 that again could be captured
serially in the hours after drug
administration occurred and and here you
see again an example from each of the
dosing cohorts and so and then here's
the il-10 data as well similarly showing
the spike in Aisle 10 release after drug
is administered so the deliverables from
this trial were many and I think I spend
a few minutes kind of highlighting this
that this is a fully human necrosis
targeted igg1 antibody il-12 conjugate
we found it can be safely and repeatedly
administered titular bearing dogs and
does elicit the expected peeking back
markers we also because we had access to
bulky disease were able to see early
biopsy the lesions undergoing treatment
and look at things like cd8 positive
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes and other
changes in histologic appearance and
trying to link all of those people are
people markers to exposures that were
captured with the pharmacokinetic
assessment and within the cohort of
these dogs we identified an efficacy
signal in two of seven dogs with bulky
or malignant melanoma we were also
similarly able to capture the adverse
events that these dogs underwent and
exhibited and all of those were
relatable to the expected cytokine
release that you would see with exposure
to il-12 so a
limiting Wikipedia dogs developed fevers
that were self-limiting they did have
hepatic ins amaba'ti again that you
would expect to see when we got into the
higher dosing cohorts and that's above
1.6 mix per meter squared we did see
some serious grade 4 & 5 events that
indicated to us that the MTD was
probably you know lower within our
dosing cohorts and we were able to
expand the cohort at the point eight nic
per meter squared dose level and really
nailed down the maximum tolerated dose
and the dog the tumor bearing dog to be
twenty five point eight micrograms per
kilo important to recognize too that
these are patients that are pet dogs and
so these are not healthy two-year-old
beagles these are ten eleven twelve year
old dogs that even though we have very
strict eligibility criteria for
hematologic and biochemical parameters
to be eligible for the trial it's
possible that they have some silent
hepatic or renal insufficiency that
doesn't exhibit itself clinically but in
essence they resemble a pretty typical
phase one human patient so they're not a
young healthy 18 year old they're you
know more representative of a geriatric
population so also I think pretty
important to really making the case here
is that the company that brought forward
this agent for study in dogs had
received the dog data and then chose to
reprioritize the development of this age
and so they opened an IND for this agent
in 2011 the dog data was collected over
about a three year period in 2007 2008
2009 and then the IND for human use was
opened at the clinical Center here at
NIH in 2011 and that data from the phase
one was recently published in clinical
cancer research within that phase one
trial they had enrolled 59 patients and
were able to identify the maximum
tolerated dose as 16.8 micrograms per
cage and that occurred at dose level
eight and just as a reminder we
identified the MTD and dogs to be 25
micrograms per keg at dose level two and
so very similar MTD between human and
dog and in fact the dog might have
hire MTD hard to say with them the
number of patients that we enrolled but
I would definitely say that at dose
level 2 this was an extremely well
tolerated job and the dog and we were
able to capture an event proof and ask
adverse event profile that was extremely
similar between humans dogs and also
echo the pharmacodynamic data being very
similar between humans and dogs and so
we've generated the data the clinical
management data and the dogs for about
$300,000 about 18 months and
unfortunately you know it took a lot
longer and many many many more patients
on the human side to really arrive at
similar findings so 7 years and 59
patients compared to what we were able
to identify and learn in a relatively
short period of time so I think that
this story really helps to understand
the trajectory of dogs and where they
could really help inform and potentially
help optimize or streamline some of the
follow-on work and people perhaps maybe
as that relates to a starting dose or
recognition of wear kinetics and
pharmacodynamic responses can be
tailored based on what we learned in
dogs and those studies can then be a
little bit more simpler and quicker and
easier to recruit on the human side so
if there's interested this is the first
inhuman phase 1 work this just came out
last august and clinical cancer research
for the NHS 12 human trial so next i
would like to change gears and talk a
little bit about our work in canine
osteosarcoma specifically in our
clinical trials that are designed to ask
questions about ways that we can target
metastatic progression so canine
osteosarcoma is extremely common canine
disease
it affects at least 10,000 middle-aged
to older large and giant breed dogs in
the United States
some estimates maybe take this incident
towards a hundred thousand or even more
dogs affected every year so extremely
common and a very serious health problem
for
dogs here in the US and and beyond the
standard of care currently is amputation
of the affected limb followed by
adjuvant chemotherapy but even doing
that only allows us to have long-term
survival or cure of three years or
longer of about five to 10 percent and
unfortunately the median survival time
overall you didn't despite aggressive
therapy is only about 10 to 14 months
and the majority vast majority of dogs
succumb to the TAS disease or spread
typically into the lung but also other
places too like the bone and soft tissue
really wants dogs develop metastatic
disease we don't really have good
effective management strategies for that
advanced stage and so drawing some
parallels between humans and dogs are
obviously a portent of oncology as a
whole back in 2009 a very nice paper
came out of our program under Jean
Khanna and melissap a loonie that really
sought to ask questions about how
similar at the genomic or gene
expression level are dogs and humans and
their tumors and this paper that the
heat map there on this slide shows you
that from a gene expression standpoint
you actually cannot distinguish dog from
human tumors and compared to a normal
healthy bone those are indistinguishable
as well so it really gives us a lot of
opportunity to think about the clinical
similarities and then have that
molecular underpinning that so similar
really support ongoing studies of this
disease and both species pediatric
osteosarcoma in contrast is an extremely
uncommon disease so less than a thousand
children are diagnosed with this disease
in the u.s. these children undergo
neoadjuvant chemotherapy with follow-up
limb Salvage even with again the
aggressive treatment approach 70 percent
of them will have long-term survival
which means 30% of them will succumb
again mainly due to metastatic disease
within five years of diagnosis and there
really aren't any good predictors or
effective treatment strategies for
metastatic disease and children either
so based on those similarities we really
have I think a lot of opportunity to
really think about ways to
study event instead of regression and
metastasis biology in the dog that
presents with osteosarcoma and learn
translationally where our targets and
opportunities could be and then relay
that to the pediatric oncology community
so lots of studies and lurcher exists in
this space to help back up the
predictability of fatal metastatic
disease within one year of diagnosis and
so these are just six studies of many
that really nailed down the the reality
of how hard this disease is to treat in
the dog and how there's a real
opportunity for us to think about
strategies that could enable a
prolongation of progression-free
survival and if we could significantly
extend progression-free survival and
dogs with osteosarcoma then we could
really feel confident about that being
an opportunity for study on the
pediatric side and so one of the studies
that I'll tell you about today is a
trial that's headed up by our colleague
and friends Nicola Mason at the
University in Pennsylvania she is
studying I hurt your new targeted
Listeria in you know therapy and has
published some really promising phase
one results in clinical cancer research
and so this observation that dogs that
receive this Listeria based
immunotherapy in addition to having
standard of care was significantly
longer than a control group of
historically control and standard of
care therapy patients so we sought with
the help of the Morris Animal Foundation
to extend upon these observations and
really nail down whether or not Listeria
based immunotherapy could have a future
not just for dogs but also for pediatric
patients so partnering with the Morris
Animal Foundation as osteosarcoma
project has allowed us to leverage our
clinical trial consortium membership
through a long-standing initiative and
fundraising efforts to understand and
and gain access to a model for assessing
new treatment strategies that are really
focused on targeting Metis
static progression to benefit both dogs
and humans and so the concept here is to
study a series of novel agents from a
variety of sources through canine trials
that I'll run through our COTC mechanism
and compare those novel agents against a
contemporaneously accruing standard of
care control arm and that allows us to
have a wholly randomized prospective
design with a one-to-one enrollment
between control and investigational drug
and these studies are powered to detect
a 50% improvement in disease-free
interval over standard of care and that
is really an important point because we
need to be able to show a significant
amount of improvement and disease-free
interval or progression-free survival to
really have that be meaningful for
adoption on the pediatric side to that
end actually this paper published in
clinical cancer research in 2014
reflects an algorithm for agent
prioritization and how this group of key
opinion leaders came to consensus on
metrics for valuing agents through a
variety of different data types and this
paper talks about how data that's
collected in tumor burying osteosarcoma
patients can be included in evaluation
scheme that helps the pediatric side
understand and rank agents that can be
considered for further study so the
comparative oncology program has taken
this on as an initiative that we spend a
significant significant amount of time
and resources towards conducting these
trials and making sure that they are
implemented with the guidance of our
comparative oncology colleagues within
both the veterinary and pediatric
oncology communities this is the summary
of current more salient foundation
sponsored austere color project clinical
trials and so at the top you see Co D Co
22 which is our standard of care arm
standard care and the schema is defined
as amputation of the affected limb
followed by four doses of adjuvant
carbon panel therapy given up three week
intervals and then
the investigation alarms currently under
study there's two of them there's tota
Co T Co 21 and co t co 2621 trial is
looking at adjuvant rapamycin as an
inhibitor of m4 again that's added to
standard of care so every dog on these
trials receives the standard of care
therapy and that they're randomized to
either receive adjuvant rapamycin or
standard of care and then our adjuvant
listeria trial that's currently open
those dogs are being enrolled again to
provide us to just the statistical power
compared to the yo 22 trial and so in
all those Listeria patients are
receiving the Listeria again in the
adjuvant form so after they've completed
standard care so we opened the first two
arms of the trial back in the fall of
2015 and were able to recruit over 300
dogs and about two and a half years sort
of just shy of three years and then when
we have that had the Oh twenty six trial
opens since the fall of 2017 and we've
got ninety one at current count out of
one hundred and ten for the target
enrollment so I'd say you know we have a
lot of success in enrolling large
numbers of dogs again I think that
reflects this is a funded trial
mechanism and pet owners really
appreciate the opportunity to have care
carried out through this mechanism and
that this is just a really common
disease as well so it it really does
serve the needs of both of veterinary
and the pediatric communities to have
these types of trials open so this is
the study scheme out for the native care
arm so dogs are screened and confirm is
eligible and they undergo surgery to
amputate their affected limb and we bank
tumor and all the creature even samples
from serum and PBMC use etc and they are
then clinically followed with thoracic
radiographs and physical exams every
eight weeks after they complete
carboplatin Ultherapy and so this is
just a snapshot of the types of dogs
that have been enrolled and recruited to
the standard of care arms we started out
165 that were randomized and then after
the process of confirming the disease
and confirming that they are free of
metastasis
we have 149 dogs that have survived the
post-operative period and started
carboplatin chemotherapy and this cohort
currently this is not only mature data
but it's pretty close to being complete
we'll have a fully mature data set in
the fall of 2019 so at about eight more
months we'll have this all complete and
ready to share with the community
currently this data set shows us a
meeting and disease-free interval of the
intent to treat populations about 5.8
just shy of six months and that's a in
line with what previous reports have
shown it might be a little bit shorter
than some of the statistical comparisons
that are out there and the other
osteosarcoma published literature
I think that that reflects the fact that
we had very prescriptive follow-up and
very careful evaluation of thoracic
radiographs both during and after carbon
functional therapy so some of that
observational bias may be to conserve to
explain why our disease-free interval is
a bit shorter than what's been published
by other investigators but I think the
key point here is that this standard of
care arm and all of the other
osteosarcoma project initiatives and
clinical trials really help provide a
strong scientifically sound backbone for
which comparison of novel agents can be
assessed particularly in a minimal
residual disease studying where we know
it's so critical to address metastasis
before it becomes clinically evident
because once metastatic disease sets in
is and is bulky the treatment options
that are effective become extremely
limited if not non-existent and that
these abdomen trials that we're
currently working on you know 21 and oh
26 trials really serve as nice proving
grounds for these agents to be
considered for pediatric assessment and
we didn't really we strive always do
engage stakeholders within drug
development but also patient advocacy
groups and specifically the Children's
Oncology Group is a major stakeholder in
our activities so we're really it's
really important to us
to make sure that whatever we do has
translational benefit for both dogs and
treatments and to that end actually
advances that the company who has
created and manufactured the Listeria
construct has now entered into an
agreement to have Austin OS therapies
move that agent forward for human
clinical trials so that relationship
between advances then OS therapies is
pretty critical and I think that the
data that we're generating in dogs is
really helping to really garner the
enthusiasm for the movement of this
agent forward and there's a parallel
product that will be produced and
licensed and moved out into veterinary
use from Erath HANA so this is an
example of where the work that we do
really have bi-directional benefit for
both children and for dogs I just wanted
to end with a couple of coming soon
points so the national cancer
institute's human genomics data Commons
or the GDC is a portal for which we are
planning a comparative initiative and
dogs that we are creating a canine
genomic data Commons it is going to be
much more really than just genomics
though and the idea here is to have the
opportunity to provide the cancer
research community with a publicly
accessible data repository of dog cancer
data that will help investigators really
have the tools and the opportunity to
query what we know about dog cancer in
context of human cancer and allows
opportunities for people to put their
data that they generate in their labs or
with their trials and studies into one
place where we can then curate a really
high-quality integrated data set from
dogs that will again help drive home the
value of studying cancers and dogs and
really open up new opportunities to have
clinical trials and other activities
carried out in dogs that are informed by
the the integration of the genomic data
between dogs and and from people
so we have an exciting time I think
ahead of us and comparative oncology we
think it's really important to help
continue to emphasize the scientific
dialogue about the value of the dog and
the dog that develops cancer naturally
within its lifespan and and how learning
more about those those patients can
really help understand where they can be
strategically placed in clinical trial
studies and other scientifically robust
assessments of the biology and drug
development so you know we certainly
don't believe or advocate that the dog
will solve all the problems with cancer
drug research and development but we
think that if there's careful
consideration of where the dog can
really inform and complement the
existing drug development activities
that involve other species and involve
humans we can get to better drugs faster
and maybe take less promising drugs off
the list sooner it's also I think really
important for us to maintain the highest
standards we can for a clinical trial
design and execution and reporting and
so to that end we spend a lot of time
mirroring and understanding how clinical
trials for humans are put together and
really adopt those best practices for
our work as well and I think finally
it's a community-based initiative and
this came through earlier in my top and
I was talking about the National
Academies workshop on comparative
oncology one of the biggest gaps really
in our knowledge has been getting a more
robust assessment and understanding of
canine specific datasets and k9 specific
reagents and relative assays in place to
help enhance those activities and really
help improve the translation to humans
so that is a challenge I think for us as
a community to continue to develop those
those data and those resources and BM
the necessary tools to help enable the
scientific discovery to continue and be
relatable to humans so with that I'll
conclude my presentation and send a huge
thank you to again lab roots and the
organizers of this event and to all of
my colleagues within the NCI and our
comparative Oncology
program and all of the various partners
collaborators and champions that we've
had both within NCI and IH and within
the drug development community as a
whole and a special thank you to our
students and member institutions and all
of the support staff the families of the
dog patients in your role on our trials
and for everyone's hard work to help
realize where the value of our study of
national Korean cancers and dogs can
really benefit both us and and now so
I'll thank you for your attention and be
happy to follow up with any questions
via email after the presentation
concludes thank you thank you dr.
LeBlanc for that informative
presentation I would also like to think
levers for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that this webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through May of 2019 and there's a final
reminder once again our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye